[Musique]
non
on les appelle tintin aux filous tintane
aux maniaques les amoureux du petit
vais-je aux culottes de golf était
aujourd'hui plus de 15 cents à se
disputer aux enchères 500 lots dédiés à
leur idole en chair record pour une
couverture en couleurs des cigares du
pharaon plus de 3 millions de francs
c'est l'une des très rares couverture
dessinée en couleur par hergé lui-même
c'est donc le cigare le plus cher du
monde 3 millions 200 mille francs
[Musique]
les brit air
depuis quelques années la plupart des
anglais mme sur l'homme tata jean ping
est peu pour voir ce qui se passe de ce
côté lâché de passage à paris pour deux
jours et je t'ai kurun voit l'importance
de tintin c'est celle de vent
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'il ya une dizaine d'années
lorsqu'on disait que nous organisons des
gens de bd envoyé pointe et çà et là
quelques sourires parfois un peu
ironique
[Musique]
gergy n'a fait que cinq couvertures dans
sa vie en couleurs directes à la gouache
celle ci s'est un temps d'amérique de
1932 après je dirais que c'est un vrai
tableau
[Musique]
cette oeuvre a atteint après
extraordinaire parce qu'elle est
extraordinaire elle est le résumé
finalement de toute une carrière de la
carrière d'hergé qui comme le
dessinateur le plus l'auteur le plus
connu dans le monde entier
[Musique]